I don't want to miss another chance, so that's why I
couldn't keep up with my wife when she escaped from prison.
Say
, I
don't know anything about him
What do you mean You're telling
me not to
trust the wrong person like
me Are you ready?
First of all, it's Ichiro. Let Hassaku
wake up the pole
and attract the
guards.In the meantime, we'll suppress the lipids
.
Are
you betraying your comrades in order to escape, or
are you complaining? In order
to be free,
you need to make some sacrifices.It ca
n't be
helped.  Hey,
I'll keep up with the opposition, no matter where it goes.
[Applause] It's
simple
.  I
got it, he didn't have any choice,
so he didn't use me as a decoy to escape
.  right